le camping c'est un choix de vie de
vacances tradition familiale raisons
financières vincent le roubaisien et
campeurs depuis son enfance pourquoi le
camping va être en lien avec la nature
vont être en lien en convivialité avec
ses voisins et puis quoi ça
salut de cannes de de silence et même
pour les enfants c'est
fait savoir qu'elle aille parce que
malade et on sait qui est quand même un
minimum de bienveillance voilà moi j'ai
pas trop aimé laisser partir au jeu tout
seul alors que si on était enfermé dans
une maison avec un jardin vrai il serait
cool entre eux alors que là ils peuvent
rencontrer d'autres enfants et donc moi
en force au chanteur plus tranquille le
camping c'est aussi des habitudes et des
souvenirs josé veuf depuis quelques
années et toujours il a choisi le
camping de limeray comme point d'étape
depuis qu'il part en séjour sur l'île
d'oléron avant je passais une nuit ici à
l'aller est souvent deux à trois nuits
en retour maintenant je fais trois nuits
à l'aller trôner au retour
puisque je ne me parlez plus de choc
mais je les ai fait à peu près tous le
camping c'est aussi parfois quelques
galères la vie au grand air c'est aussi
composer avec les éléments urbains
sommes ok on avait en étant tente on a
été inondée on a dû rentrer sécher tout
pendant deux jours donc l'année d'après
on est parti les parents avaient décidé
de nous emmener à montpellier en raison
cette fois héros inondations camping où
les deux fois